in this video we're going to talk about
one of the most common ways to measure
solute concentration in a solution and
that is
molarity and molarity is defined
as the number of moles
of solute the thing that we are
dissolving
in a solvent that divided by
the liters liters of
solution so let's just do an example and
see if we can calculate the molarity
of a solution so let's say
that i have this is a container here
and i'm going to dissolve some sodium
sulfate
in water so sodium sulfate is the solute
and
water is the solvent together they give
us the solution
and let's say we have a total the total
volume of solution is 250 milliliters
of solution and that solution
is made up of just to give ourselves a
bit of a refresher
we have the solvent which is
h2o it is water in this situation and
you might say do we have 250 milliliters
of water
and the answer would be not quite
because of 250 milliliters that's the
volume of the water
plus the sodium sulfate and so we're
going to have some sodium
sulfate in here and let's say we know
that we have 35.5
grams of sodium
sulfate that is the formula for
sodium sulfate and so given this
information
how do we figure out molarity well the
first thing you might say is okay i know
the number of grams of sodium sulfate i
need to figure out the number of
moles and to figure out the number of
moles you'd have to look at the molar
mass you could figure that out from a
periodic table
of elements but just to speed us along i
will help you out a little bit here
the molar mass of solar sodium sulfate
molar mass is
142
grams per mole
so given everything i've now told you
see if you can pause this video and
figure out the molarity
of this solution what's the molarity of
the sodium sulfate
in this solution all right now let's
work through this together so first
we want to figure out the number of
moles of
solute so we can start with the mass of
solute that we have right over here so
we have 35.5
grams of sodium
sulfate and now if we want to figure out
the number of
moles see i'm going to multiply this
times something that would cancel out
the grams
and so i don't want grams per mole i
want moles per
gram and so i could write this i could
multiply this times
for every one mole
of sodium sulfate and a 2sof
we have 142.04
all right this way grams
of sodium sulfate and you can see very
clearly
that that will cancel with that and
we're left with moles of sodium sulfate
so we'll get a calculator in a second
and just
take 35.5 and divide that by
142.04 and then to figure out molarity
we want to divide by the liters of
solution
so up here we have a calculation for
number of moles and then the liters of
solution 250 milliliters
is the same thing as 0.250
liters of our solution and now
we can just use our calculator to figure
out what this is
35.5
divided by 142.04
equals that and then we divide that
by 0.25
i could just throw a 0 in there and then
that gets us that
right over there and then we can think
about how many significant figures
we have so we have three over here we
have one two three four
five over here we have three over here
so i would say that we have three
significant figures
and so we would round this right most or
this
9 right over here well if we round that
up
we get 1.00 if we were to go to three
significant figures
so that gets us 1.00
and then you might say what is the units
here and what people will normally say
is this is one point zero
zero molar when you see this capital m
right over here
that is the unit for molarity but
they're really talking about the number
of moles of solute per
liter of solution and we
are done